[Musique]
france 2022 c'est notre rendez vous
comme chaque lundi avec vos choix de
leur dire bonjour bonsoir raphaël
bonsoir à vous tous j - 55 avant le
premier tour et on a toujours le
sentiment que cette campagne a du mal à
décoller la faute entre autres à
emmanuel macron toujours pas
officiellement candidat même si selon
des sources ça ne saurait tarder
conséquence l'élection peine à captiver
les français ils ne sont vous le voyez
que 71 % à se dire intéressés par le
scrutin selon une enquête ipsos sopra
steria c'était dix points de plus il ya
cinq ans jour pour jour sa campagne a
elle aussi peine à s'élancer valérie
pécresse plombé ces derniers jours par
de nouvelles défections et des critiques
acerbes en interne a souhaité lui donner
un nouveau souffle hier au zénith de
paris le récap politique de la semaine
est signée bill halte à rabais et autres
goût riche
ce devait être son grand meeting son
moment mais dans la salle et autour les
partisans de valérie pécresse parle
surtout des défections de son camp vers
celui d'emmanuel macro ces deux puisque
macumba effets et ses débouchés chez
nous s'il y en a qui veulent partir
qu'ils y aillent on l'est on ne
retiendra pas principal des flexions
eric woerth ministre du budget de
nicolas sarkozy mais dans le zénith de
paris le centre ne semble pas intéressé
valérie pécresse c'est plutôt à droite
août voire à l'extrême droite ou
pas de fatalité ni aux grandes et
classement ni au grand remplacement
eric zemmour lui répond à distance en
jouant sur le thème du préférer
l'original à la côte
et dans cette campagne aux allures de
mercato d'hiver eric zemmour a réalisé
une prise de choix stéphane ravier le
seul sénateur rassemblement national
marine le pen de son côté continue de
dérouler une campagne de second tour
avec ses grands sujets régaliens cette
fois la place de la france dans
l'alliance atlantique moi je souhaite
que l'on sorte du commandement intégré
de l'otan et non de l'otan
jean luc mélenchon lui veut tout
simplement la sortie de la france de
l'otan propos que la france ne soit plus
le wagon de l'otan la france sera pays
non-alignés
toujours à gauche l'homme qui monte
l'homme qui stagne fabien roussel et
yannick jadot été reçu un colloque ville
écologie nous voulons construire 200
mille logements sociaux par an et
réhabiliter 700 mille logements par an
pour tenir nos engagements climatiques
il y à des millions et des millions de
françaises et de français qui sont
contraints de prendre l'automobile et la
question n'est pas de les culpabiliser
la question c'est de leur offrir des
solutions
à la rame dans les sondages mais dans
une barque à moteur en martinique la
maire de paris anne hidalgo s'en prend
aux pollueurs des antilles
moi je me bats et je veux me battre pour
que à l'échelle internationale il y ait
un tribunal international qui soit
compétent pour les crimes des consignes
et voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine à
la semaine prochaine
on va revenir à présent sur le grand
moment censé lancer la campagne de
valérie pécresse était sa rencontre avec
les militants ils étaient plus de 7000
hier au zénith
oui raphaël et les meetings c'est pas
son truc à valérie pécresse elle admet
volontiers toujours un peu maladroite
elle a beaucoup été critiqué sur la
forme mais aussi sur le fond avec un
discours jugé très à droite et notamment
la réutilisation du terme de grand
remplacement qu'on entend plutôt
habituellement dans la bouche d'eric
zemmour un discours qu'elle assume en
tout cas ce lundi on en parle avec
karina chahbour bonsoir karina vous
étiez pour france 24 au meeting de
valérie pécresse au zénith de paris sur
la forme tout d'abord elle souhaitait
donner un nouvel élan à sa campagne est
ce qu'elle a réussi alors pas à en
croire effectivement les commentaires
sur les réseaux sociaux à en lire les
unes de la presse ce matin ou même à
regarder les mines déconfites embarrassé
de certains caciques à droite pendant ce
meeting même si il faut le reconnaître
sur la forme tout avait plutôt très bien
commencé la salle était comble il avait
même fallu ouvrir une seconde salle à
proximité au cabaret sauvage un proche
du zénith les axes les accessoires avait
été minutieusement préparée on a vu les
drapeaux français des encarts des
t-shirts une grosse pièce pour mettre
l'ambiance de la musique beaucoup de
jeunes au premier rang notamment et puis
effectivement les ténors ont tous joué
leur partition vous savez les quatre
perdant de la primaire ce qu'on appelle
désormais les quatre mousquetaires eh
bien ils ont tous fait un discours très
millimétrée dans lequel ils ont a fait
part de ses idées qui leur sont chers
mais sans empiéter sur valérie pécresse
ils se sont tous montrés unis derrière
leur candidate et puis au bout d'une
heure elle est arrivée elle s'est offert
un bain de foule puis ce discours de
plus d'une heure elle était très elle
était pressée par son entourage de se
dévoiler de révéler de sa personne et
c'est vrai qu'en toute fin de discours
elle a parlé de sa famille elle a parlé
de ses difficultés elle a évoqué ses
mentors politiques simone veil jacques
chirac et nicolas sarkozy grand absent
de ce meeting dont le nom a été
copieusement applaudie mais il est vrai
qu'à la sortie si de nombreux militants
qui veulent croire qu'ils sont acquis à
sa cause se sont dits gonflé à bloc on
sentait bien et d'autres reconnaissait
qu'effectivement elle n'est clairement
pas à l'aise dans cet exercice et tous
disaient que c'était plus une candidate
du fer c'était le terme qui revenait
souvent qu'elles étaient sincères et
qu'elle n'était pas une grande oratrice
est elle même l'a reconnu ce matin chez
chez nos confrères elle est plus à
l'aise sur le terrain avec des contacts
directs avec les français que sur une
estrade alors sur le faire justement que
veut faire valérie pécresse peut être un
indice il a avec un clin d'oeil comme
très appuyé à l'électorat de droite avec
vous l'avez 10 h rennes cette expression
du grand remplacement reprises à eric
zemmour en réalité à renaud camus une
expression très controversé oui
absolument alors avant cela il a livré
disons sa version de sa france sa
nouvelle france et là avant avant de
parler de cette expression elle a
déroulé si vous voulez un petit peu là
coché toutes les cases de la droite des
valeurs de droite la famille le travail
plutôt que l'assistanat le travail qui
doit payer plus que l'assistanat la
responsabilité le libéralisme économique
l'écologie qui ne doit pas être punitive
mais au contraire qui doit être une
écologie de solutions et puis elle a
aussi beaucoup de tacles et emmanuel
macron en fait tout son discours elle
s'en est prise son adversaire s'était
emmanuel macron elle n'a jamais cité le
nom d'eric zemmour seulement voilà vous
venez de le dire la phrase que tout le
monde a retenu c'est pas de fatalité ni
aux grandes et classement ni au grand
remplacement et l'emploi de cette
expression qui est au coeur de la
campagne 2le du candidat d'extrême
droite eric zemmour selon laquelle les
élites organiserait le remplacement des
populations européennes par des immigrés
non européens a retenu l'attention de
complotiste les démographes absolument
et qui a donc a été critiquée par les
observateurs par ses adversaires par
toute la classe politique dès ce matin
alors elle s'est défendue d'avoir repris
à son compte cette idée elle dit plutôt
la voie le dénoncer dénoncer cette idée
mais c'est vrai que l'utilisation de ce
genre de deux termes très controversé
marque d'une certaine façon son
ambiguïté et peut-être la difficulté ce
rôle d'équilibristes quels acquis et de
devoir composer avec toutes les
sensibilités de la droite dite
républicaine qui va du très droitier et
riddes et eric ciotti pardon jusqu'aux
plus sociales xavier bertrand et ce au
moment où précisément une partie de son
électorat et tenter et séduites par les
thèses d'eric zemmour et d'autres
caciques des républicains et bien eux
ont multiplié les défections au bénéfice
des manuels mâcon merci beaucoup karina
bisch et vous suivrez donc valérie
pécresse tout au long de cette campagne
à la présidentielle on vous retrouvera
donc régulièrement sur notre anglais
mais avant ce premier meeting donc de
valérie pécresse où en étaient donc ces
fameux baromètre 1 pour la presse et pas
seulement d'ailleurs les enquêtes
d'opinion alors selon un sondage ipsos
sopra steria publié vendredi dernier
emmanuel macron perd un point il est
crédité de 24% mais c'est toujours loin
devant valérie pécresse marine le pen et
eric zemmour donné au coude à coude eric
zemmour lui gagne un point et demi
plutôt à l'aise sur les plateaux
télévisés il est aussi épauler vous
allez le voir par un réseau de jeunes
militants très motivés le collectif
génération z c'est un reportage signé
clovis casali et thibaut jean pierre
photo de groupe avant opération collage
des affiches la plupart refusent de
montrer leur visage peur des
conséquences au travail ou à
l'université
alors qu'il se prépare une voisine en
profitent pour voler discrètement des
affiches direction poubelle et 1,9 et
lancés depuis un immeuble
eric zemmour attise les passions et la
haine
faire simplement
[Applaudissements]
ils ont la vingtaine et ont rejoint
génération z plus de dix mille jeunes
venus de mouvements identitaires
souverainiste du rassemblement national
ou du parti les républicains c'est
l'union des droites cher à zemmour
mari en est convaincu celui qu'ils
surnomment le z va sauver la france on
montre qu'on est présent sur tous les
terrains
à la télé que sur les meetings que dans
la rue arrêter toute immigration et
revenir à des valeurs plus
traditionnelles
le message de l'ancien journaliste les
séduit à deux pas des champs elysées le
qg d'eric zemmour marie prépare une
vidéo
d'abord répétition enfin eric zemmour
dénonceront emplacement c'est aussi à
travers ces pratiques puis
enregistrement
thème du jour l'excision dans le monde
ya toute une communication qui est
développé sur les réseaux sociaux pour
qu'on soit présent pour qu'on soit vue
pour qu'on soit actif il ya des cellules
de here i pod donc de réponse sur les
réseaux sociaux et des cellules de
communication de partage sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont très actives c'est des
centaines de messages par jour
zemmour sexistes et réactionnaires pas
pour marier ses camarades de lutte
on est un peu les propos d'eric zemmour
directement
il a dit que nous en tant que jeune
aujourd'hui on est en manque d'une
france qu'on n'a pas connues cheveux
exactement ça je trouve ça très vrai
maintenant quand tu dis je suis fier
d'être français directement
[Musique]
les limites en fait
je n'ose plus dire je suis fier d'être
français
génération z se fait voir et entendre
la campagne présidentielle a bien débuté
et eux sont là
sujet inter-générationnelle par
définition les droits de succession ou
combien l'état vous prend en cas
d'héritage et les candidats et bien ils
ont bien leur idée sur la question oui à
gauche on est plutôt pour renforcer les
droits de succession surtout sur les
plus fortunés à droite plutôt pour les
alléger pour l'ensemble des français en
tout cas la plupart des candidats
veulent réformer le dispositif à l'heure
actuelle la france est l'un des pays au
monde qui taxe le plus les successions
et les donations chez nos voisins
allemands par exemple la fiscalité
successorale et nettement plus
avantageuse pour les entreprises comme
pour les particuliers
reportage signé de notre correspondante
à berlin allemagne et
les droits de succession sont au coeur
de la campagne présidentielle française
est comme souvent l'allemagne est citée
en modèle on va comprendre pourquoi dans
cette entreprise berlinoise
ici on fabrique des moteurs industriels
depuis trois générations
l'entreprise a été créée par le père de
courtes mais un seul en 1927 quand j'ai
repris l'entreprise on a commencé à
faire de plus grosses machines mais ça
c'est vraiment notre produit standard
lorsqu'il a légué son entreprise à son
fils mathis aucun droit de succession
n'a été prélevée en allemagne les
héritiers d'entreprises familiales d'une
valeur de moins de 26 millions d'euros
peuvent bénéficier d'exonérations
d'impôts allant jusqu'à 100 % il
s'engage en contrepartie à conserver
leurs employés pendant au moins sept ans
l'avantagé très clair l'état fait tout
pour protéger les entreprises familiales
et si les droits de succession sont
aussi bas c'est dans l'intérêt de tous
ceux qui travaillent ici
une fiscalité qui chouchoute la colonne
vertébrale de l'économie allemande les
entreprises familiales fourni 58 % des
emplois du pays mais le patrimoine
familial lui aussi est bien mieux
protégés en france un parent peut donner
cent mille euros à son enfant sans avoir
à payer d'impôts en allemagne le plafond
est quatre fois plus élevé pour des
enfants c'est extrêmement différent
puisque chaque enfant en allemagne pour
chaque parent à 400000 euros
d'abattement donc si on pense que les
rideaux de sa mère et de son père on en
est à 800 milles par enfant en france on
en est à 200 milles c'est quand même une
grande différence des droits de
succession qui font régulièrement
l'objet de débats en allemagne comme en
ce moment la campagne présidentielle
française mais aucun gouvernement ne les
a pour l'heure remise en cause
on en vient je vous l'annoncé donc un
autre portrait des lecteurs oui on part
cette semaine à la rencontre d'abdoulaye
kante policiers il n'est membre d'aucun
syndicat mais défend sa profession
autrement notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux il est très actif ou encore à
travers un livre qu'il a écrit intitulé
policiers enfants de la république son
portrait est signée de nos reporters
julie d'une des neuf et florence vimines
depuis 89 je suis policier j'ai commencé
par les secours donc ce qu'on appelle
les amène 17 je suis parti dans le 93 en
seine saint denis ont occupé notamment
de tout ce qui était en effet en
séquestration viol et aussi des stups un
événement qui m'a beaucoup marqué des
attentats de novembre 2015 j'étais avec
mon équipe plume intervenant au stade de
france
et aussi on a été sur la soupe sony
je suis né en france et à mes deux ans
je suis parti vivre au mali donc le pays
de mes parents et l'âge de mes 15 ans je
suis revenu en france
quand vous venez de l'afrique et que
vous devez intégrer des corps régaliens
en france c'est sûr que vous devez on va
dire faire plus que ceux qui sont dans
ces corps la sortie d'école avec les
parents
le racisme je les ai connus si je dis
que je n'ai pas connu je serai je
mentirais et encore une fois quand on
pas le racisme dans la police j'ai
toujours que la police française n'est
pas raciste mais il ya des comportements
racistes qui doit être bannie et dénoncé
la policia pouvoir de répression mais
aussi un pouvoir de pédagogie à faire
je vais à la rencontre de jeunes qui
sont pour une exclusion scolaires et
même ce côté social qu'est ce que par
nous il y en a qui ont déjà subi des
situations difficiles avec des policiers
belges il relance en manif le respar
hall d insulte pour les mêmes devant les
laisser tous à vos souris oui il ya des
comportements inacceptables et qui ont
été dénoncés est jugé souvent on a
affaire à des collègues qui ont tendance
à faire entre parenthèses les énerver
gratuit mais aujourd'hui que vous les
jeunes vous avez la loi avec des
policiers qui contrôlent exprès que les
noirs et les arabes c'est qu'ils sont
légitimes parce que depuis bien
longtemps l'institution était vue comme
une institution qui couvrait le racisme
et
ce n'est pas que ça
si j'étais président de la république je
créerai un super ministère de la
jeunesse afin de que les jeunes se
morfond plus leur offre de l'espoir je
créerai un ministère de la diplomatie
nationale et du consensus afin que les
gens se parlent et qui est en fait un
dialogue instauré
on en entend beaucoup parler dans cette
campagne sereine le pouvoir d'achat
préoccupation numéro un des français
une préoccupation d'ailleurs qui ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui oui c'est même un
thème classique de campagne
présidentielle on va voir ça avec une
archive de georges pompidou du 19 mai
1969 alors candidat du parti gaulliste
eu des airs à la présidence de la
république il fut le bilan des acquis
sociaux des années durant lesquelles il
était premier ministre de gaulle était
alors président et vous allez le voir
les enjeux de l'époque étaient bien
différents de ceux d'aujourd'hui écouter
et frigidaire
ils ont doublé pendant ces 6 m
les télévisions en triple et
l'équipement ménager qui est soulagement
de la femme de l'ouvrier la société de
consommation la société de consommation
je ne crois pas qu'il faille il a
détesté quand il s'agit de donner à la
femme d'un ouvrier ou à la femme la
paysans un frigidaire ou une machine à
laver ou une cuisinière électrique
je crois même cet excellent
et c'est tout pour cette semaine nos
campagnes raphaël merci à chacun on vous
retrouve lundi prochain avant bien sûr
le 14 mars france 2022 l'heure du choix
deviendra à partir de ce moment-là
quotidien et puis bien sûr vous pouvez
retrouver cette édition sur les réseaux
sociaux et notre site internet france 24
points comme également une nouvelle page
sur notre site où sont regroupés tous
les contenus liés à la présidentielle
merci encore h rennes prochain journal
dans trois minutes rester avec nous sur
france 24
on